there are people on there who are very
pro-vaccine who are anti-mandate and
there are people on there who have not
been vaccinated but aren't anti-vaxx
because they're just not these vaccines
um right and and and i i put myself in
that in that camp it's just uh yeah no
it's not about that but we're you know
they're going to try and characterize it
as anti-vaxx because because that
that's a
that's a that's a that's a dog whistle
for for certain people in this story
right as soon as you call this like
calling somebody a conspiracy theorist
it's just that you just get to paint
them with that brush and
well it's really oh you're one of those
a
scent that is applied to you to keep
others away right they're not going to
convince you or me
right or anybody who knows us well i
mean you know
am i an anti-vaxxer
i don't like these vaccines i don't
think they're wise they're too narrowly
focused there are too many design
failures built into them they're too
novel we know too little we know that
the trials that were done to establish
their safety were not high quality they
weren't large enough they didn't go on
long enough there are problems here that
a reasonable person can look at does
that make me anti-vaccine well let me
tell you something
i have given i don't know how many
lectures to my students about the glory
of the mechanism by which vaccines work
i think it's one of the most beautiful
stories i know i'm extremely pro-vaccine
in a general sense i will tell you that
watching pharma do this has made me
concerned about adjuvants in a way that
i wasn't before right i worry that
there's something about the way we
generate vaccines now that we and the
public need to know more about because
it's having effects on our immune system
that are more general than this basic
vaccine mechanism which i find so
beautiful but there's no way i mean you
know this this
michael gunner this australian guy
who every so often says the quiet part
out loud and we get to hear
what the plan really is you know who i'm
talking about i think he's from northern
australia and he every so often he says
something colorful about
you know
your personal vaccination status is
irrelevant if you are anti-mandates you
are anti-vaxx you know that guy
right yeah so anyway
is that they're gonna use that stigma
against anybody who has any reservation
about any vaccine or any measure that
might be used to uh to get people to
take it
and the point is anybody
with any level of intelligence
whatsoever knows that that is not a
definition that one could reasonably
apply if anti-vaxxer is a thing
then surely somebody who is pro-vaccine
and anti-mandate doesn't warrant it
somebody who is pro-vaccine in principle
but not pro-every single vaccine doesn't
warrant it right it's obviously a trick
it's a magic trick and frankly it's not
a very good one right it's not
compelling you have to want them to fool
you if you're buying that stuff and
if that's you you know
uh
you have to look yourself in the in the
mirror
yeah and the whole the whole again the
whole
mass formation idea is to get you
focused down on stuff right it's it's
like hypnosis the idea is to get you so
that you're just focusing on this dot at
the tip of your nose and you can't even
resolve it's a dot i mean it's that it's
that hyper focus
and so we've been hyper focused for a
long time on kova deaths right
then you scratch at that a little bit
and you find out well it was out of
death with or of and and next thing you
know we're battling over him on the
antivax or vaccines again it's too
narrow the point is that if we'd had a a
complete and authentic public health
response we would have said hey
how we doing in terms of all-cause
mortality you know a lot of reasons
people check off this mortal coil how we
doing and the answer is we're sucking at
it right 2000 was bad but 2001 was even
worse so by that objective measure we
can say whatever it is until total we're
doing worse and that's the conversation
we should be having so i worry every
time it gets pulled back down to
you know is it about these vaccines you
know because that's that's not they are
a component of what should be a very
rich tapestry of of things that we would
have in our tool kit at at the public
health level but it's always about that
and that's it and uh and you know we
don't even have brett at this point i
can't even point you to a single study
that says let's compare
unvaccinated people to vaccinated people
but these people got early treatment too
i don't know what that data looks like i
have strong suspicions i can infer it
from studies that don't you know that
sort of triangulate on it but we don't
have the actual data
how is that possible to not have that
data i mean we've seen this this general
pattern which is
um i mean i hate to say it but you can
predict what the public health response
to something will be if it's actually
promising they don't like it right and
that should not be a pattern that is not
a pattern that suggests error that is a
pattern that suggests some other plan
and
it's uh it's appalling and i will just
say you know if you want to peek into
the resistance movement you know there
was this very good piece i would guess
that you saw it john campbell put out a
couple days ago on his channel about the
actual number of people in britain he's
british the actual number of people who
died of covid
right
and it was shocking right but here's my
point
john campbell is
absolutely welcome and on the radar of
people like you and me
he's pro-vaccine
he has been
very good at analyzing the data around
early treatment and ivermectin and he's
been courageous about talking about it
that's what the resistance movement
sounds like inside it's people who don't
have the same perspective on what makes
sense and what doesn't make sense but we
are coming to
agreement on what the tools of
measurement are that actually work
right
in the resistance movement everybody
knows that all cause mortality is an
important thing that is rarely conveyed
we know that we want autopsies done
because autopsies tell you something we
can't find out otherwise and we know
that the level of autopsies has been
artificially reduced and that suggests
that there is an obvious desire not to
know what kind of harm is being done so
it is a big tent right you're gonna see
that big tent on the stage tomorrow at
this march
because
you have people who have arrived from
you know as we began this discussion
they've arrived from
dozens of different paths to an
agreement that something has captured
our focus as you're pointing out and it
has mesmerized us into behaving in a way
that is actually harming us and
you know waking up from that
it's not going to be fun for a lot of
people but let me tell you the longer
you wait the less fun it's going to be
yeah that's
that's the main point here is look we
got to put a stop to this now and and
the way mass psychoses or formations are
stopped is with brave people standing up
saying
no let's stop we just let's stop
and so
uh
speaking of which we mentioned that you
know
every single time if there was something
favorable they
didn't like it um that data that john
campbell was talking about where they
showed that there was 17 300 people in
the whole covet experience all two years
had died of covet specifically who
weren't otherwise you know burdened with
a comorbidity
that came out because of a freedom of
information act request that data had to
be pried out and that should have been
put out there and broadcast by that same
organization if they were doing the
right thing right but instead you have
to pry it out and every time somebody
says hey chris what do you think of the
cdc report i'm like
uh i'm going to dig into it it's just
going to be crap you know
because i know that they're going to use
redefinition statistical sleight of hand
they're going to ignore stuff the bad
study design it's just it's just been
all it's just been a horror show i mean
this whole thing on
natural immunity right
the cdc
as recently as just a week ago when they
finally admitted oh hey natural immunity
looks kind of cool they were using this
really ridiculously underpowered
kentucky sort of database sort of
sleuthing thing where they only had 290
examples to look at and then they held
that out it's like oh yeah vaccines are
better when we had this extraordinary
million-plus case count case-matched
cohort study out of israel that said the
opposite yeah
the cdc should have been there saying oh
here's why we don't like that study and
here's why we love they didn't they just
put this crappy study out and everybody
sent it to me like what do you think of
this i'm like uh
just
yeah
nothing wakes them and that tells you
that what they are is somehow a
a pr outfit right it's all broadcasting
things and you know one thing that has
been just
uh shockingly obvious to those of us who
have dug into it
is the level at which what people are
claiming as evidence pointing to the
public health narrative and its
prescription
is based on accounting fraud
right and you know you could look at one
instance of it and you could say well
maybe that's an error right maybe they
got the categories wrong
as an error but the number of places
where they have created a definition for
a category and they have shunted people
into it in order to amplify certain very
predictable messages right
what's the message the message is that
covet is very dangerous and it's killing
lots of people what's the message it's
that the vaccines are reducing harm to
people right what's the message is that
those without the vaccine are clogging
hospitals it's like they will just take
anything that points in that direction
and they will reorganize definitions
however they have to do it to to make
that appear to be the case and
any analysis that just simply doesn't
start with a
um a presupposition about
what landscape we're in sees that that's
nonsense and so you start to tune it out
right what do you think of this latest
cdc report why are you asking me that
has the cdc gotten anything right here
i'm not aware of it right they've been
wrong across the board so
at some point you tune that out and you
go looking for something that isn't
consistently wrong
right something that is open to various
possibilities and you'll find that
that's a very vibrant discussion it just
you know to your earlier point the
interesting stuff is on the fringe why
because it was driven there
right the natural people who would be at
the head of the conversation of
figuring out what's going on in covet
and what we do about it those people
have been driven to the edge they've
either been silenced they've been
threatened and they've chosen to
self-censor or if they haven't been
willing to self-censor they've been
driven to the edge and so you know what
that's where you'll find them
absolutely yeah i was um very early on i
i really cottoned on to the whole flccc
guys and i was helping them set up early
webinars and then i've been on the board
for a while and
and i
it's gotten a lot better since but i
remember in the dark old days maybe i
don't know six eight months ago their
facebook page would get taken down they
were getting youtube strikes left and
right and having you know channels
pulled down and they were saying nothing
other than they were highly qualified
medical doctors discussing data that was
it they weren't out there railing
against you know what they thought you
know pfizer was full of crooks or
anything like that there was no nothing
that would rise to libel they were very
careful and and
watching
that level of friction and hostility
that came at them was astonishing
never i'd never seen anything like that
before maybe you had in your battles
well that was astonishing you know it's
astonishing in a way i'd never seen it
with doctors and there was something
just
impossible
to stomach about watching these
obviously highly dedicated people who
actually save lives for a living they do
it
day in and day out
being treated as if they
were up to something right i mean it
just
it couldn't possibly be more the inverse
of what was happening you had doctors
trying to be doctors trying to sort out
a live situation that we've all been
told is of utmost importance
and being demonized for the effort
because their conclusion didn't match
the public health authority which was
obviously wrong
and then to watch the tech sector
leap to attention and start treating
them as if these were somehow you know
dangerous monsters it was just such a
preposterous
show of force on the part of whatever
the thing is that is arranging
the narrative
that you know
either you got it when you saw that or
you didn't and
um
yeah i'm glad those dark days are are
are over but
um new dark days are coming
yep
yeah i i agree so
it's
we got a little dawn coming i mean i do
feel that the censorship has lightened
up a bit now for the march tomorrow i'll
tell you
um
there's gonna be
there's this march and then and then
there's a bunch of people speaking so
they've invested in jumbotrons and the
stage and sound and all that stuff and
uh
uh unfortunately i won't be there to
speak that would have been fun uh
history moment but um there's a bunch of
bunch of the doctors i think are very
familiar names and then there's going to
be uh vaccine-injured people there
talking who finally get maybe a national
platform voice i can't even imagine how
awful it must be to be like the the
mother of of maddie gary stephanie gary
and know that you were doing the right
thing and then as soon as things went a
little wrong like the system just
basically said we think your daughter's
just nuts
and
no no support no it's just awful um
but to hear from there'll be union
people there firemen um
uh just it's this is this is where i
think we get to see brett
just how broad this really is because
this isn't a bunch of anti-vaxxers this
is americans
who have some questions who feel like
they weren't allowed to ask those
questions and that felt wrong
and they they don't want to put up with
that anymore so that's what i'm excited
to see is
um
you know that this is the beginning of
something i hope which is us finding our
voice again
and yeah so i don't know if i could pick
up on a theme
there's something about watching the gas
lighting of the injured
right if this was an honest effort to
control the pandemic and people had been
injured because we had a vaccine that
worked it had a unfortunately high price
a certain number of people
you know rolled the dice and it came up
bad for them we would take care of those
people right and the point is
you did this so that we could be safe
and we could go back to life and the
point is these would be heroes we would
not be gaslighting them we would be
accepting that they were harmed they
would be getting free care for the rest
of their lives for the cost that they
paid on the rest of our behalf and to
watch them gaslit tells you what kind of
monsters we're dealing with
the other thing that does that
for me at least
is the withdrawal
of
treatments that work early
right the idea that you're going to
simultaneously tell us we have this very
dangerous disease as you withdraw
therapies in which there is no profit
but that work
that is a level of indifference to human
suffering that is almost impossible to
imagine so those two facts
if i need to think about what's really
going on here
i can check in with them and i can say
well at the very least whether this is
people making a decision in a conference
room or it's an emergent process it's a
monster right it is willing to actually
literally harm people
with a vaccine and then gaslight them
over whether or not they were harmed it
is willing to prevent people from having
medications that might
protect them might save their lives and
no process that is capable of those two
things
can can be defended it's not it's not an
accident and
there is no decency to it
[Music]